une semaine avant le scrutin manuel
latraverse bonsoir bonsoir on va faire
un petit tour rapide si vous le voulez
sans du pays
en vain sa grenade en quelques minutes
donnez nous identifions peu les points à
surveiller
mais au québec c'est ce que le coin
premier que tout le monde veut sauver
lycée la région de québec ici pourquoi
ci par là que les conservateurs espèrent
faire des gains le premier d'entre eux
luis à leur raconter des gérard deltell
mais y en a d'autres aussi
peu après ce pour les conservateurs ça
se déplacer si j'ai cet hyacinthe mais
leurs espoirs premier juste à côté
victoria ville richmond arthabaska le
maire alain reyes ça c'est des gros
espoirs et on espère que le débat sur le
niqab est une erreur va finalement le
donner aux conservateurs ce qui manque
dans la région de montréal on est dans
une dynamique complètement contraire
c'est les luttes npd parti libéral sur
l'île de montréal
mais ce qui a changé dans la campagne
par rapport à ce que j'avais fait la
même entre le même entretien avec vous
il ya deux mois
c'est l'effet bloc québécois qui vient
brouiller les canons
tu es monté et qu'il y ait brouiller les
cartes dans beaucoup beaucoup de courses
au québec le bloc l'eau ils ont les
meilleurs espoirs je voudrais c'est dans
la couronne sud de montréal et dans la
couronne nord ici là les comtés où sur
l'île le chef des chiefs a cédé compter
qu'on veut sauver pour d'autres raisons
mission quand je parlais les espoirs du
bloc québécois premier si les comtés où
le parti québécois un bienfait ça
commence surtout autour de laurentides
labelle rivière du nord vers du nord
c'est l'équivalent du comté de pierre
karl péladeau donc ça va être à
surveiller sa rentrée sur la donne
difficile pour les knicks ont finalement
en mode défense et non beaucoup beaucoup
de circonscriptions au québec
et là tout le monde retient son souffle
pour voir comment est ce que tout ça ça
va bouger si vous voulez au cours de la
prochaine semaine vont se cristalliser
les intentions de vote
et si je sais être doux sur sa montée
pour réussir à franchir le cap dans
l'électorat francophone qui lui
permettrait lui d'aller faire les gains
qui veut faire non seulement sur l'île
de montréal
mais ailleurs au québec comment est ce
qu'on le disait là le 2 ou quand on a
sur ce plateau lancé cette longue
campagne électorale
on dresse une course à a3 et a4 au
québec au québec ça reste une course à
quatre
et c'est ça qui m'a les cas oui ça reste
une course à quatre où les prévisions
sont très difficiles je vous donne un
côté où on était on prévoyait le mpd
libéral tout d'un coup le bloc monte
plus le bloc monte plus ça aide le parti
libéral plus parti libéral monte plus ça
aide le bloc québécois cause de tous les
effets de vases communicants qui rendent
les prédictions mais bon c'est un cliché
on a beaucoup dit l'élection va se jouer
en ontario ce toujours le cas
qu'est-ce qu'on surveille mais deux
choses à surveiller principalement il ya
la bataille de toronto ceci est vraiment
principalement le centre-ville de
toronto
des duels très serrés entre le npd et le
parti libéral en ce moment bien sûr la
vence du parti libéral dans les
intentions de vote les rassure quant aux
courses que là mais là où le plus ça va
se jouer c'est toute la couronne et si
le autour de toronto ça commence à
scarborough qu'on arrive sur la 417 sur
la 401 et toute la couronne ici brenton
mississauga ceci tous les comtés qui ont
donné leur majorité aux conservateurs en
2011 là dans une époque dans la campagne
où le npd avait des espoirs dans
quelques comptes et scarbrough brampton
vraiment la donne est en ce moment dans
des duels libéral conservateur
c'est très très très serré en ce moment
même les stratèges sur le terrain
veulent pas faire de prédictions on en
parlait un peu plus tôt dans le dans
l'émission c'est ce pourquoi aussi les
conservateurs sont tellement d' attaque
pour essayer de freiner justin trudeau
passe quand tous là dans l'ue une
cinquantaine de pompiers qui vont faire
la différence mais ça se prolonge aussi
ses grands l'ontario ça commence à 1,28
ou pour l'instant le pdo l'avantagent
doit protéger ses sièges mais ça se
prolonge comme seul toute la ceinture
jusqu'à windsor où là il ya plusieurs
courses qui peut faire la différence
dans l'ouest
avantage bien sûr en alberta sas une
évidence pour les conservateurs mais
quand même
l'alberta dans l'histoire électorale on
n'est pas jamais beaucoup de temps parce
que l'après midi que les conservateurs
gagnent tous merci bonsoir ça fini leur
démarche de 80% cette fois ci il ya
vraiment des cros à surveiller pour des
raisons complètement différente
akhalgori on est dans une dynamique
libéral conservateur
au moins deux comptes et à calgary où
les libéraux ont de très très bon espoir
de l'emporter
les gros candidats des candidats
vedettes qu'on monte admin tools un pays
est déjà un tout petit conte et edmonton
strathcona leurs espoirs c'est de faire
comme un colimaçon autour de la ville
pour aller chercher d'autres gains parce
que qui a gagné à 2 min à edmonton ses
vertus remontée lors de la dernière
campagne mais le parti libéral est pas
perdant non plus la dent donc ça va être
intéressant le colimaçon des colimaçons
là on la retient et on finit rapidement
par la colombie britannique
parce que l'autre cliché on dit souvent
ça va se terminer tard parce qu'il y
aura des luttes très chaud de là bas est
ce que c'est vrai ou penseurs et ça
souvent pas été vrai alémanique est vrai
donc je voudrais jamais devrait cette
fois ci plus la course est serrée plus
ça peut être vrai ici là dans
l'intérieur de la colombie britannique
c'est là que le npd espère aller faire
quelques gains aux dépens des
conservateurs
à vancouver on est souvent dans une
lutte à trois entre le parti libéral qui
veut reconquérir ses anciens comptes et
le npd et les conservateurs et l'île de
vancouver c'est là où le npd est déjà
bien présent où il espère faire dauguet
y en a un tout petit sic on voit pas
pour l'instant les seissannais du
koraline y la bête mais est ce que dans
ces courses là le parti vert vient
brouiller les cartes
sauf si c'est à surveiller d'ici lundi
prochain très bien évidemment vous
travaillez derrière avec les vrais
catcheurs ne fait des excuses rapide
vous aurez lu les vrais karl du prochain
vrai kart avec les bonnes couleurs
interactive les noms des candidats
ça va être encore plus clair des
sous-régions tout le pays des coupés
comme ça pour essayer de donner une
pertinence à l'ensemble de l'histoire
ça sera fait merci menu un vrai plaisir